Welcome back everyone
It's Charlie, this will be my full Invincible
Season 2 Episode 2 Video There's a whole bunch
Easter Eggs and references, so we'll break it all down.
If you're brand new to the channel,
be sure to subscribe to get all the episodes.
Careful for spoilers
if you haven't seen the episode yet, we'll just start
at the beginning, work our way through, shot by shot.
Talking about Easter Eggs
wtf moments, starting with the episode title
In about 6 hours I lose my virginity to a fish.
is a reference to a couple of different things.
In the context of the episode.
It's about Mark thinking
that he's going to have to marry Queen Aquaria,
who's played by Tatiana maslany,
who She-Hulk in the Marvel Universe.
she also voiced one of the Lizard League characters
in the Adam Eve prequel.
I'll explain later in the video.
there are a lot
of actors on The Invincible show
that play multiple characters.
So you might recognize some voices
showing up all over the place.
the title is also a joke on Mark Still Being a Virgin,
which they make fun of later in the episode.
And just the twist in general,
like the whole idea of him theoretically
having to marry this Atlantan is a reference
to Robert Kirkman's parody of the Superman Comics.
In a twist during those Recently, in an interview,
Robert Kirkman revealed one
of his favorite types of stories
were like the really wacky over the top comic book
type of stories, as opposed
to like the really down to earth kind of stories.
in one of the stories
he specifically referenced was the time that Superman
almost wound up
marrying a mermaid in the OG Superman Comics.
Back in Superman issue number 129 in 1959.
So a long time ago there was a character called Laurie
Le Mars who was secretly a mermaid
that Superman briefly had an intense relationship with
and almost got married to
but essentially that really weird wacky
kind of adventure
is the inspiration for these invincible comics
that this is based on.
In the episode the actual opening
scene is their high school graduation.
The principal is named Winslow.
In the school is named Reginald Dell Johnson
High School.
You probably detected the Easter egg here.
The Winslow character is played by real life actor
Reginald Veljohnson,
who played Carl Winslow during Family Matters.
So it's like this crazy meta Easter egg.
They even animate the character
to look just like real life.
Reginald Dale Johnson apparently Robert Kirkman,
just a really big fan of Reginald Bill Johnson
back in the day
when he was first creating the Invincible Comics,
the graduation speech is meant to be a metaphor
for all the challenges that Mark is facing,
trying to prove himself trustworthy to everyone,
prove to himself that he's not like his father omni-man
that he can still be a hero.
is sort of foreshadowing the challenges
that he will face in how his power
levels will have to increase
They finally bring back the William character.
In this episode, Invincible is absent
because he's been working for Cecil
at the Global Defense Agency and he's been working
overtime trying to prove himself like 24 seven.
Adam Eve is here because she's considering herself
temporarily retired from active superhero business.
But there are continuing things in the background,
sort of trying to pull her back into the game,
so to speak.
They kind of address that with her arc in this episode.
Eventually, whether she wants to or not,
she will be forced to become a superhero again.
Invincible is in the middle of dealing
with dark seismic who they teased at the end of season
one is basically him
cleaning up that mess from the season one finale.
They use the fight scene mostly for a comedy like
Dark Seismic, referencing that he's not a professor
because actually I never really taught at university,
even though he has a Ph.D., which he makes fun of later
at the graduation ceremony,
like Case against Higher Education, because Dr.
Seismic is crazy.
they don't actually explain what his Ph.D.
is in maybe geology because he's so obsessed with that.
His whole bit is that he wants to reclaim
certain parts of nature, but not all of nature.
Just the geological formations, like all the rocks,
all the metals, that kind of stuff.
that's why he jokes about them
being able to keep all the wood base buildings
And it's why he's
attacked the Washington Monument,
because it's made of rock and metal
in the original comics, Doc
Seismic was meant to be a parody of both mole
man from the fantastic
Four comics and Shocker from the Spider-Man comics.
notice.
He also talks to Invincible
about himself in third person,
as if he's narrating his own comic book panels.
All of his henchmen,
the Magma Nights he found underground during season one
When Principal Winslow talks
about testing your limits and learning how strong
you truly are, it's a reference to Invincible
is growing power levels
this season and in the future, he's destined to be
the most powerful village my who ever lived, like
basically the most powerful person in the universe.
Next to Adam Eve.
theoretically. Their power levels are infinite.
Like there is no actual limit
to how powerful that they can get with training.
Seasonal.
And a lot of the other people in this episode
addressed the issue of superhero collateral damage.
Like when Invincible, for instance,
essentially destroys as much stuff as he's saved.
So initially, it's
kind of a wash for a lot of characters.
It's the same problem with Adam Eve,
like she tries to help people, but also winds up
causing a lot of collateral damage
accidentally without realizing it.
they're a couple of jokes about Winslow
making up a bunch of inspirational quotes.
Apparently, he does it all the time, too,
because like Mark comes in, it's like,
did I miss all the fake inspirational quotes?
They also reveal what everybody's middle
names are in this episode.
Ambers Middle name is Justin.
Mark's middle name is Sebastian Sebastian
probably comes
from his mother's side of the family
because that's not a built to my name.
Williams Middle name is Francis In Adam.
Eve's middle name is Eve, which is how she came up
with the Adam Eve name in the first place.
when they throw their caps, you notice
that Mark accidentally uses too much power
and almost throws his cap into orbit.
in. They give Principal Winslow the invincible title
trope, like the opening scene trope of someone
almost saying the name of the title, but then stopping
short of them saying and just flashing the logo.
notice there's some continuity
with the state of the logo from the logo
in episode one, it's still red and cracked after last
week's episode because of the events of episode one,
it's the same damage reflecting the other universe,
the evil version of Invincible
and all the stuff that happened, But it cracks
a little showing the original blue logo inside,
but with a black invincible logo
to show you more multiverse.
Easter Eggs likes the idea of multiple
different versions of Invincible Crossing over
all that invincible storyline stuff is Angstrom
Levy related stuff.
there's a lot of multiverse
related storytelling right now, but
the multiverse stuff on Invincible
was actually written back in the early 2000s
So just a coincidence that it's happening right now
when Marvel is in the middle of their multiverse days,
like we just had the Loki season two finale,
which is heavily, heavily gets into the multiverse.
I talked about this in my episode one video too,
but there was actually
a marvel crossover
with the Invincible Comics back in the day.
Like he crossed over into a Spider-Man comic.
So technically, the Marvel Universe is just like
another universe inside the invincible multiverse.
also hoping that we see a crossover
with the boys TV show
just because it's Amazon
and Amazon does both of these shows.
so they could have a crossover with Homelander
the boys characters just as easily
and just canonize the boys
universe is another universe inside this multiverse.
They celebrated Adam's tree house from last season.
She's still living on her own, but she continued
attending school so that she could graduate.
She's not going to college,
like Mark says that he wants to.
They all talk about their plans for the summer.
She's going to continue doing humanitarian work,
avoiding superhero business for now.
Mark still working for Cecil 24 seven.
Amber is working for a local politician on the election
campaign, doing community
work at the center that we saw during season one.
Williams seems like he's the only person
who's actually interested in doing anything
that like a normal kid would do before college,
like actually enjoying his summer.
even though there's a whole subplot with Invincible
getting accepted into college with Amber,
I don't think any of us expect that to wind up sticking
like there's no way that he's going to be able
to go to college and have a normal life with Amber
and also be a superhero.
even if you haven't read the Invisible comic book,
you probably sense there's just way,
way too many threads out there
that are going to demand his time.
But there's no way
he's going to have time to go to college
also probably going to wind up
destroying his relationship with Amber.
a lot of this part of the storyline is stuff
that they're adding that was not in the comics, though.
Like he had a brief relationship with Amber,
they blew past that really quickly in the comics.
just because there aren't that many original comics
that they can adapt for the TV show
and they want to do like seven seasons of the TV show
in their hour long episodes.
So they expanded a lot on characters stories.
so for instance, there's way more Amber stuff
going on this first half of season two
than there was in the comics.
is the same thing with Mark's mother, too.
Like,
there isn't nearly as much story on her in the comics.
Adam Eve references the reconstruction of Chicago
in the wake of Invincible
fight with Omni-Man during the Season one finale.
The interesting bit here with the booths
that Adam Eve creates is that invincible.
Seems like he anatomy can actually get drunk
from drinking
the alcohol despite having super physiology.
Maybe she just specifically tunes
their beers to have way more alcohol
so they can get drunk as opposed
to like Amber and William,
who are normal humans If you think about it,
Captain America, for instance, in the Marvel Universe,
has way less power and he cannot get drunk
no matter how much he drinks.
if Invincible is like ten times, 100 times
more powerful than Captain America,
he shouldn't be able to get drunk.
I think it's mostly to set up the Virgin joke
with the Virgin Mighty
because she also kind of pokes fun at him
for being a virgin still,
which is also a bit of foreshadowing
to not getting into too many spoilers.
If you haven't read the comics,
There's a lot that winds up going on between him.
Adam Eve, even the Amber character,
even though a lot of Amber stuff
they're adding to the TV show, even
with the veiled termites in the future like Anissa.
But that's like a long ways off.
Let's just say Mark will not be a virgin forever.
they introduce the Shape Smith character played by Ben
Schwartz, who's also the voice of Sonic.
You probably recognize him from some other TV show.
He's done a bunch of stuff.
he's also playing a couple different characters
during this episode.
but the shape Smith is a bigger character
in the comics.
he's another Martian who snuck back with the astronauts
during season one, impersonating
one of the crew members who they left behind,
who we see at the end of the episode with the sick
was they kind of set him up as the replacement
for Martian Man, who was a parody of Martian Manhunter.
Steve Smith himself is also a bit of a martian
Manhunter parody because his powers are exactly
the same as Martian man The whole idea
is that he's obsessed with becoming a superhero,
like he sees Martian man on TV on the broadcast.
It's like,
Wait a minute, I'm a martian. I can do that too.
I want everybody to love me on this planet.
there's no sinister plan going on behind him
or anything like that.
It's mostly a comedic bit with him
just trying to pretend to be
a human really, really badly,
like completely failing at it.
Pretty much everybody he interacts with knows
that something is up, like what is up with this dude?
during the meeting,
though they also said that the idea of Invincible
taking care of the squids from Mars
who are on their way
to earth at the end of the episode,
Artemis gets himself into trouble
trying to help rebuild apartments in the park, showing
that he isn't really considering the big picture.
They kind of addresses with her talk with her father,
even though her father is a terrible person.
even though Adam Eve wants to help people,
they're trying to show that a lot
of the superheroes in Invincible
are similar to the superheroes on the boys,
in that they're very narcissistic
and usually only think about themselves.
Adam. Eve isn't that bad, but she's kind of like that.
Like she's not really thinking about the conflict
as a lot of her powers.
when she winds up inadvertently hurting
all those people, you could say that
she also braided it to make a community reference.
If he didn't realize it's actually
Gillian Jacobs doing the voice of Adam Eve,
who played Britta on Community.
Marks Man tries and fails to
sell their house, trying to help them move
emotionally on from what happened with Omni-Man.
They also reference how they clean up
collateral damage in this universe, too.
Cecil usually hires teams of contractors
to rebuild a lot of stuff
outside of like major city reconstruction projects.
so effectively, the U.S.
government kind of pays for a lot of this stuff.
But you have to imagine
that a lot of Cecil's department's funding
comes from a lot of the technology
that they highjack from a lot of these slaves.
so it's almost that they can develop or create
as much money as they actually need at any given time.
So it's not that big of a deal.
like if they can make all this advanced technology,
they probably access to a lot a lot of quick money.
They continue addressing Mark's obsession
with proving himself
to everyone, to Cecil, to the rest of the world,
that he can still be a superhero.
He's not going to turn out like his father.
There are a lot of moments.
The question that during the episode, too,
where he seems like he could go either way,
but that's also meant to be highlighted with this other
universe version of Invincible, who definitely went
evil in the idea that in most universes,
Invincible does wind up siding with his father.
in this main version of Invincible
is like the odd man out in that he did not turn evil.
This also sets up the bit
where she goes to confront Cecil
about what's happening with Mark
and sees Donald in the answer.
A lot of people's questions,
or at least address a lot of people's questions,
not fully answering it, but at least addressing it.
how was Donald here seemingly walking around?
None the worse for wear
when he was blown to bits during season
one in the comics, Donald is a cyborg,
so I'm guessing on the TV show.
What they'll say is that Cecil probably
just had him rebuilt using some clone body parts
and some mechanical parts and replace what was lost
and that's how they'll explain.
Donald has no memory of actually dying because it also
seems like Cecil doesn't want him to remember
what happened.
merrily guess right now, just based
on this type of trope, is that they'll say on the show
that Cecil has resurrected, quote unquote, Donald many,
many times, that he's died a bunch of times.
This isn't the first time that's happened.
They go back to the Guardians of the Globe.
We're getting their asses handed to them by Immortal
during their training, Bulletproof.
Seems like he's the only one who's doing fine.
But he is way,
way more powerful than everybody else on the team.
a lot of this storyline,
though, is to put Rex blowed in his place
because he was such a big butthole during season
one and he's sticking up there training.
He can barely handle duplicate wants nothing to do with
him, kind of giving him a taste of his own medicine.
Like he cheated on Adam Eve with her during season
one in it also sets up shape.
Smith joined the team, but they need as much
help as they can get, so they need shape.
SMITH Even as weird as he is, I love the way
that they all kind of pick up on how crazy.
It's like, Wait, what?
What did you just say? Like,
you seem so weird. merrily.
Guess is they'll figure out he's really a martian.
Pretty soon. late.
They can definitely tell that he's lying to them.
they also use this duplicate scene,
the shower scene here to remind you
that her duplicates can feel everything
that the other ones are doing.
So like the one out here talking to her
explode can feel the other two
who are still getting in on the shower
with the immortal they use the memorial on TV
from the previous Guardians of the Globe roster
that Omni-Man killed to give shape.
SMITH The idea to replace Martian man on the team.
love the idea that he's just eating frozen pizzas
but not bothering to cook them
in the mascot of the pizza business,
there's also a pizza themed superhero.
He's probably got these
because he's obsessed with being a superhero.
It's like, by superhero pizza.
during the broadcast.
They also reference Aquarius to set up
Mark's storyline later in the episode.
Mark flies past the burger joint
where he used to work in season one,
where they've been at multiple times during the series.
He just met with Cecil there during episode one,
and it's also where Adam, Eve's father, is working now.
he goes to Midnight City,
which they mentioned briefly in season one, the pick up
dark wing sidekick Night Boy,
who's taken the mantle since Omni-Man killed
the original Dark Wing basically using his gear
to continue being a superhero.
It's meant to be like a big Robin Nightwing parody.
but the way they're using him on the show,
his personality is a little more unhinged,
kind of like Red Hood's.
but the whole idea is
the Darkling was their Batman parodies.
This is more of like a Robin Nightwing parody.
Midnight City is their parody of Gotham City
within the invincible universe.
It's called Midnight City
because it was cursed by the Midnight Magician
before the events of season one back in 2000.
That's around the time
the Invincible comic book was first published.
So it's a bit of a reference
to the origins of the Invincible comic book.
But when he killed himself.
That's what laid the curse on the city.
Like the act of killing himself,
basically enveloping it in a perpetual darkness.
Darkling
also had the ability to use the shadow dimension,
which is a reference to Batman always seeming
like he had superpowers because he had a clever way
of using darkness and shadows to his advantage
on his nightly patrols, taking out supervillains.
Notice Ben Schwartz, who just got done voicing Shave
Smith, is also doing the voice for this random thug.
There's a lot in this episode of actors
playing multiple characters, like the person
who's voicing Knight Boy voices,
like two other characters in the series.
there's even a brief moment during their fight
when Invincible pulls in Omni-Man kind of move on, know
boy threatening to get him killed by the knight
creatures from that dimension until he takes them back,
showing that even though he wants to be a hero, he does
have it in him to be just as bad
as the other villains reminds.
Like, is it just like the other version
of Invincible in the multiverse who all turn to evil?
The shadow verse is basically like another dimension.
It's kind of like a parody of the shadow
dimension from Marvel.
Invincible, taking Amber to Vegas for a date
is meant to be a reference to all the times
Omni-Man took his mother to other countries for dates
all the time.
They also remind you about the physics
of being a superhero.
Like, you know,
I can fly you to Italy like another country, but
all the skin would fly off your body
if we did it faster than under our.
Then he's forced to answer for Omni-Man
killing of Aquarius
and they have all the jokes about him
almost marrying his wife.
She's played by Tatiana maslany,
like I said, who also played She-Hulk in the MCU.
She also played one of the Lizard League
characters, Lizard Queen, during the anime prequel
The whole idea, though, is that the Atlanteans
and the Invisible Universe are super powerful
and they're threatening to destroy the entire
Eastern seaboard if he doesn't go through with his
while this is going on.
They said that the whole Lizard League storyline,
which seems like it's going to become a bigger thing
in future episodes, generally.
They're meant to be like a combination
mash up of cobra from G.I. Joe.
There's a reference to the terror drome
at the end of the episode.
Like that's their base.
Everybody that watched the G.I. Joe TV show
some of the internal politicking
with like different members
like Supreme Lizard trying to hijack
the group is also a reference
to some of the internal politicking
within COBRA of G.I.
Joe, like Cobra Commander versus Serpent or Supreme
Lizard is meant to be serpent or basically.
they're also kind of a parody of the Serpent Society
from Marvel and Cobra, also from DC.
Different COBRA organization
just sounds like Cobra from G.I. Joe.
Serpent Society will actually be
some of the villains during Captain America
for the movie that they're working on right now.
there's been a long running gag in the MCU
that Kevin Feige is going to use the Serpent Society
and Captain America movies in the context
of the invincible universe, though, King Lizard,
who started the Lizard League is actually like a mutant
who basically gave himself powers
it seems like a lot of them do have some mutations
that give them some low level powers.
but some of them are just wearing suits
they explained prior to the events of this season,
King Lizard been arrested.
He is one of the villains that Invincible
winds up facing early in the comics, though.
while he's been in jail, Supreme Lizard tried to usurp
temporary control of the Lizard League
until he obviously shows up at the end of the episode,
killing him when they go back to the Atlantis
storyline, this Atlantean guard is also voiced
by the same person that just got done voicing Nite Boy
He winds up having to fight the death dweller
who's kind of like their version of the carrot.
Then from Aquaman and DC They jump back to Invincibles
mother who's trying to sell their house
with her coworker here.
He's played by Cliff Curtis, pretty notable actor
for what seems like a relatively small role.
But here's the connection.
It's Robert Kirkman, who also does The Walking Dead.
Cliff Curtis was also on Fear The Walking Dead, so spry
how he got him to be on this series.
There are a lot of Walking Dead actors
that show up throughout Invincible.
Really good example is The Immortal is played by Ross
Marchand, who played Aaron
on the original Walking Dead series Notice
when Invincible defeats the depth dweller,
Cecil clocks that he was weak to its sonic attacks
and has a global defense agency make a note of it
and start developing weapons as contingency plans
in case they want to kill Invincible.
exact same thing he did with Omni-Man during season
one and preceding the events of season one.
They showed him developing all kinds
of contingency plans, trying to find ways to affect
will termite cells
in case he needed to take Omni-Man out.
Turns out he needed all them, even though
none of the things that he tried were actually
successful in stopping Omni-Man
they also follow up on this whole idea
in the post-credits scene in the other universe
with that evil of Invincible,
who explains that their global defense
agency was able to kill his father using
special quantum bombs and they were able to get him
when he was forced to sleep.
So the idea is that
there are versions of Cecil out there in the multiverse
who do find ways of eventually killing
and stopping this termites
Then they reveal what happened to that original
astronaut shape Smith had been impersonating, revealing
that the squids used him to take a martian spaceship
enter heading towards Earth to try and take over.
They'll probably address that like invisible prey,
try and face them in the next couple of episodes.
At some point
when Shape Smith is lying to the Guardians of the Globe
about how he got his powers, saying
that he got them in a random industrial accident.
That's a joke about classic comic book tropes
like classic Stanley Marvel heroes.
A lot of them, a lot of them got their powers
from random industrial accidents and when the Lizard
King returns, killing Supreme Lizard, he's actually
voiced by Scoot McNairy, who was in Batman v Superman.
But he's using a very different type of voice,
so you wouldn't know it was him
unless you watched the credits then.
They reveal in the Post-Credits scene
that Angstrom Levy travels
back to that other universe that we saw in Episode
one with the evil version of Invincible
and learns from this version of Invincible
how they were able to kill his father
and stop him all because he's looking for ways
to actually kill Invincible in the main universe.
The Angstrom Levy storyline
might conclude with the first half of season one,
or it might be for the entire season.
Not really sure
because they're only doing four episodes
then going on break and they're doing the second
four episodes early next year.
you also notice that in this universe, Cecil
and Donald are both women.
I don't know what their names are.
There weren't a lot of information
about them in the credits,
but basically it's the exact same characters
But women versions
there's a whole bunch of Easter eggs and references
in the episode, if you spotted any that I didn't
talk about in the video or you have any questions
about what happened in the episode,
just write them below in the comments
in my full Episode three video we'll post next week.
Also, because we don't have Loki episodes
anymore, I'll be posting
my invisible episodes
a little bit sooner after they air.
they were like ten different videos
I had to make this week
just because so many big things came out
all at the same time.
So tell me a little bit longer to get this video out
Click here for my full Loki Season
2 Episode 6 finale video and click here
for all my other Invincible videos.
Thank you so much for watching.
Everyone. Stay safe
and I'll see you guys in the next one!